hello hello
hey Aaron hey roomie
welcome guys
hey God
what is that CB Afton hello
I'd say that
Jesus all Hey Taylor
hey harmonic sounds hey Luxy
hey family
hey Harden
snow salmon
hello
the hard on meow lady hello
true sighted welcome back
thanks for uh always coming back to
these
maybe the whip snap
hey Rita
how's everyone doing
everyone's doing well I suspect you have
a sharp eye for fashion be sure to stop
by whenever you're about
good good
I'm assuming uh everyone who has the
game has beaten it and
I think I'm the only one who hasn't
I'm good I'm good
just thought I'd pop on for a normal for
a stream at a normal hour today
I'm always coming on here at two in the
morning
foreign
you beat it twice nice
hello Salazar
hello the gaming Pringle
a yammy yummy
CB Afton if you two don't mind if you're
going to bed before either of you come
up with another clever idea to get us
killed or Worse expelled have a good
night
to CV Afton
yeah those of you who have beaten it
um is it worth another playthrough in a
different house I assume so
[Music]
oh please tell me you have an answer for
me about the butterflies hello sirona I
think I'll play through as a Hufflepuff
next how are you because I heard you can
go to Azkaban did you ever find lordcog
I did thank you we had a good
conversation hey Master Kush
I don't ask for details of your little
chat and I'll refrain from telling you
to be careful thank you thank you harumi
I appreciate it whatever your plans I of
course
your owl mentioned you're needing my
help with something I do
I thought you might be just the person
to do a favor for my friend Dorothy
sprottle in Upper hawksfield yeah I've
seen the Hufflepuff quest Quest
questline has asked about my friend but
it's quite short she's lovely
was a friend of mine
in fact I
I've seen her a few times since Aiden
passed but the Pub's been so busy lately
I've not been as attentive as I'd have
liked I wonder with you how long was the
segment at Azkaban she may need some
help collecting ingredients for her
supply of wig and World potion
could retrieve
retrieve the full
ators and such
I'll try to go and see her when I can it
would mean the world to me and Dorothy
Aiden was bringing the box of letters to
me when he was taken ill I couldn't tell
you where he might have dropped it your
my dad is your fan you'll find the
Hamlet just north of Hollywood thank you
to your dad please do give dot my love
I've got too many quests on the go right
now I don't know what to do
hello Mike Mike we're a phone
like the name
uh
uh Billy mcstings
hello to Lily kid's dad
there are there any more um
Sebastian quests I can do right now
well hello my dsv YouTuber okay dsv
any tutorial videos
um I haven't beaten the game so I don't
think I'm
qualified but I will when I've beaten it
let's do this
so I can learn glaciers
[Music]
glacius looks like some fun
I have a theory that the unspeakers were
studying ancient magic that's why
they're so secretive because of how
powerful these forms of ancient magic
are
yeah
makes sense
that would explain a lot about the
department of mysteries
uh I am not the same dude from Star Wars
Theory
he's a partner on the channel but we are
not the same person
yeah we have a similar voice
I'm a Slytherin yeah
hobby time hola
uh
where am I going
Liam thank you
thanks for translating your content to
Spanish yeah you bet that's uh that's
one
Star Wars theory is Canadian
do I think the unspeakables were
studying ancient magic yeah I think it's
absolutely plausible
who has the Spotify Channel what do you
mean
you'd like the hat thank you
this doesn't seem to make sense as far
as a quest to learn glaciers goes
but I'll do it
you pop a bunch of balloons and you
learn glaciers interesting
uh Star Wars Theory runs nerd Theory
with uh Josh from den of nerds
where's this last balloon then
am I blind
does anyone see where this last balloon
is
can I
I still don't see it
hey Aaron
thank you for joining behind me
oh there it is
wait is that one
no that didn't count
hey gpg
welcome welcome
the trees
ah there it is
brilliant
I still haven't beaten this game I tend
to avoid main story as much as possible
in games I'm not so much complete as a
Explorer yeah I feel the same way
um
but I also haven't logged too many hours
to be honest
been having trouble trying to balance
playing the game with um
you know making videos
but my plan is to put a bit more time
into it now
Boba Fett with the Super Chat
love your content keep it up thank you
thank you thank you I appreciate that
chasing quests will naturally lead to
exploration
you've got an Xbox one yeah I think it's
supposed to come out on Xbox One in May
right April May
Rachel Kern sending so much love
enjoying your content for a long while
thank you thank you
I'm I have I'm not doing anything in any
kind of an order I'm just running around
like a headless chicken
hey Calvin
thanks to whip snap
May 5th
yeah I mean maybe it'll get extended but
at least they're you know gonna do it
properly
it's better that they take their time
and do it properly I think it was April
but it got extended to may but
it's always kind of ported differently
which Welsh guy
laughs
my character you want to see my
character name
there he is
in all his glory
what do we think
uh there's no one that's Welsh
who narrates the videos
as myself and
um
well pretty much just me now actually
that narrates them
and I'm not Welsh
how did you get James Canberra thank you
thank you
no I've got lots of quests
I completed the list of tasks you
assigned
wonderful I trust you became more
familiar with your broom through the
process
yes Professor that's good to hear keep
it up and perhaps one day you'll have a
spot on the Quidditch team if black ever
permits thanks for the uh confirmation
true sighted with those tasks out of the
way let us get started I think I'm like
25 done maybe
I've done one trial
well done
recommend that you practice your new
spell here in my office before taking it
out into the world
okay what to do now what to do now
Pruitt who can tell me
which popular character is a member of
the Pruitt family
can you swipe it in the chat
who's a Pruitt
Lovejoy
who
Molly yes Molly Pruitt she married into
the Weasley family
oh I have to learn uh Wingardium Leviosa
that's what I've got to do so I can do
the Feld Croft
Quest so that's next
wingardium
levioso ah
is it Leviosa or Leviosa
Ernest hello I always watch your videos
before sleep still can't believe how
many details these films and books have
yeah
thanks for watching
niku hello
hey guys if you enjoy the stream please
give it a like so that I know to do them
because if no one likes it I'll assume
you hate it
where do I go for this
hey Yannick Yannick
yeah it's my first place well I have two
characters but I haven't beaten it on
either characters so
uh it's technically my first playthrough
oh can I buy them in hogsmeade
oh okay let's do that then that sounds
easier
good good thank you
what would I do without you guys
I just wish you could adjust the field
of view on Console which is which you
can't do right now
Joey love your vids hi from Ireland
hello
such a good game honestly great
favorite thing they've introduced in a
long time
prefer this to the Fantastic Beasts
films that's for sure
I'm in Slytherin
which shop do I buy these uh
plants from
I can't get them at J Pippins
or is it here
is this it the magic
neep okay
I'll go there
no it's not the magic need oh which is
it
here
dog wheeing oh yeah yeah that's it
that's it dog weed and death cap okay
okay I've got it
thank you
do you guys prefer this game to the
Fantastic Beasts films it's my question
yes or no
do you guys think this will prompt
Warner Brothers to make a follow-up game
or film
I think it will
yeah I agree it doesn't feel more
pottery
thank you
good for you he had all those foul
goblins are hiding
Kilted Garb was this
let's put this on guys
oh that's on it
Kilted
look at this huh
what do you think
my my
it is the ultimate drip
okay what do I need here
what do you think a Hogwarts legacy two
would consist of I guess I could go
further back in time that would be cool
or they could expand the world and just
um make other schools available
hello oh hello sorry I'm in a better but
Desi I was just gold in some of the
plants for spitting and nipping I
suppose it's my own fault for putting
more than four to a tree by the way
Beatrice welcome to dog oh that wasn't
that cool so if you guys have feedback
how I stream then let me know because
I'm still new to it getting used to it
do I speak too much do I speak too
little obviously engaging enough
you don't knock the mandrakes oh
hi rooting you'll be the next one to
drop dead and Iman uh I'll do the dark
arts for sure yeah
what do you have for sale
see we show you some of what's available
what do I need I need to buy a venomous
tentacular right
oh I'm
so wise purchase
until you go far
oh and Mandrake okay
show you some of what's available
should I just buy one of each
or should I buy two to be safe
yeah Diagon Alley DLC would be nice
okay I'll just buy the one
and I'll just come back I'll just come
back if I need it doors
so now just to find some enemies guys
right yes
[Music]
is this the best place to go for this
because he wasn't making it up
well we've come this far Miss Willards
he might get an awesome about him
confronto
no worries
um yeah so I have to use it on multiple
enemies at once so where's a good place
to go for that
spiders probably right
the spiders will be good for this
surely
no worries
yeah I'll use uh the Mandrake
hold on
or I need to use the venomous
spectacular oh I had some already
to learn
which scene
is a Resto momentum used in the film do
you guys remember
and who's it used to buy there's one
notable particularly notable
occurrence
does anyone can anyone tell me
that's it
there we go
simple enough
yeah it was when Harry fell off his
broom and Dumbledore used it
I wish to get to use my ancient Magic
I completely forget it exists
I don't think I need it most of the time
though
is this um butterfly quests
worth it
yeah it's a fast one okay I'll do it in
a minute oh it gives you parents
I don't care
I love the uh extended revelia
Professor black my sister might I
suggest a band on Magic in the library
someone has been sneaking into the
Restricted Section and crested of Bloom
seems to think of the library as her own
personal arena in which to practice her
latest incantations it is most
disruptive one might consider peeves
tame by comparison to such antics
hmm
Rebellion
really happens
level 19.
look at me
thanks for joining Aaron
where's the um
herbology class again
foreign
imagine solving a riddle that I
mentioned and then
play competing with them
all right wingardium levios are coming
up folks
100 hours my mind John
it's quite the commitment
I think I've played like 25 hours or
something not very much
on this character anyway
assignments Professor pays to hear it
Professor Weasley will be too oh I've
got to go return that question you're
coming along Gareth Weasley or whatever
his name is Professor heckage tells me
she taught you Wingardium Leviosa
when executed correctly you should be
able to pick up Boulders as though they
were sprigs of Spaceport
Thanks James
yeah I'll definitely be making videos on
the
on theories within the game
well done feel free to practice
Wingardium Leviosa here in the
greenhouse I've set some crates out for
you in the Next Room
where are these crates
today's my birthday can you say Happy
Birthday Happy Birthday harumi everyone
say happy birthday to varumi
harumi harumi
okay I've got the hang of it
Brandon I know that thank you though
everyone tells me that
um this is my first playthrough I have
two characters but I haven't beaten the
game with either character
[Music]
okay I'm gonna go to fell Feld Croft now
I think
Rebellion
oh my my
revelio
Don't Mind If I Do
what do we have here
treats for me
[Music]
I just wish you could change field of
view guys I hate how zoomed in it is
[Music]
so one thing that really bothers me
about this game is the field of view
which you can't change on PlayStation
oh Philip thank you that's good to know
I didn't know that
uh PS5
alohomora
is it your dream to do YouTube as a
permanent job absolutely this is my job
but it did take some time to get here
yeah I've done a lot of these someone's
caught
true scientist I think uh you're onto
something
I worked in marketing before I did
YouTube
not particularly exciting
um what got me into into Harry Potter
um my grandfather bought me the first
book when I was a kid
Rebellion
I don't know there's no best house they
will have
their advantages
I'm slightly partial to suthering but
I don't think it's the best it's just
what I like
um
um I don't know it's hard to say
okay
I'd probably be in
I don't know probably not Gryffindor
maybe Ravenclaw or so they're in
yeah so this is kind of my
introduction to streaming and I'm
getting more comfortable with it so the
idea is to do a little bit more
streaming in the future
yeah they all have pros and cons uh uh
where's this Gareth Weasley fellow
foreign
Legacy is a solid
9 out of ten I would say I'll
take away one point four
no field of view on Console no no change
in field of view and console and it
could be the world could be a bit bigger
I guess
but I mean that that might come with
time so
revelio
handy resource indeed your Field Guide
I'm most pleased to be included
flipendo once you've completed the
necessary tasks come and find me in the
greenhouse
thanks Lucent
Alvaro have you found a giant chessboard
no I haven't
which film was the worst in comparison
to the book
I don't know maybe uh
maybe Half Blood Prince but I mean I
liked Half Blood Prince still both
versions
the book was very good
what are you up to now
Italians and a historians uniform it was
brilliant which Quest is this
thanks for joining Ben
you got a Gryffindor Sycamore ones 14
quarter inches
astronomy
okay I don't want to do that
yeah I'm supposed to get uh conjuration
right
why were you sad to realize that Scorpi
hello Gareth I have those dried Billy
wigs things you got them incredible
getting them was more work than I
expected I'd like to be paid for my time
of course didn't think it would be that
much trouble but I'm happy to pay for
your help thank you again I'll let you
know when I brewed myself anyone noticed
he has the exact same face as Sebastian
[Music]
exactly the same okay I'll allocate one
more Talent Point what should I
should I put it into
is this good
do I want this
IQ mastery
I use accio I'm gonna I'm gonna get
accio mastery
foreign
when do I get bombarded
a never-more mermaid
uh yes I went dark wizard
path
oh you get one bombarded late game hmm
okay I'm gonna do the main quest
it's got to felcroft
it's a short Journey out there
ah upper hogsfield now where to find
this bottle
if I do other live streams what kind of
uh
streams would you want to see
I know
revelio
couldn't bring them
whoops
hold on a second guys
foreign
hey guys I just have to go for uh
10 minutes so I'll be back in 10 minutes
so bear with me
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hello hello
what did I miss
you guys were discussing chocolate
everyone stayed
look at that
top three chocolate Cadbury crunchy
Snickers
not about the game or stream
like your voice way of speaking thanks
I appreciate that
thank you
that's that settled
too easy
oh that's a good point
[Music]
yeah sorry about the Sheep guys my bad
oh let me get this uh
it's going to say Porky uh flu powder
Rebellion
nice to see you my young friend
who is this seems to be the problem yeah
well ask
obviously based off of uh trelawny
well as it happens I have what you need
well Grim is going to
be talking of me gratitude I didn't even
know I had one
thank you
it's too easy
it's around here can sleep
alohomora
you can kill the Grim
m
that's all this then
oh elf made Ivory gloves
foreign
what is this
it's in here
what does this mean on the map
oh near a field page
where though
now forget it
oh
hey
welcome cuddles
abandoned long ago no doubt
Titans are people thanks for watching
thank you
cuddles gaming what's up my guy not much
what is this a cat
all right
yeah if you don't pet every cat in the
game you you don't have 100 percent
if you guys didn't know
I'm gonna pet every single one
otherwise you haven't beaten the game
so I don't think anyone's really beating
it
love the game
yeah Round Rock wins if you don't bet
the count exactly
everyone knows that
I'll make a video on it
what do we have here
I should investigate Rebellion
nope
how do you get uh you know you can
change the appearance of who yeah I know
I know I know I know
Obi-Wan thanks for stopping by
over here quietly
I'm glad that you received my owl we
need to stay low and remain quiet does
he what's going on why are we all the
way out here as promised I did some
investigating to find out what Harlow is
up to I followed him to the hog's head
I noticed him reading a letter all I
could see was that it was signed by and
bore the Seal of Victor Rookwood and
one other thing
hello mentioned you to his colleagues
[Music]
just before I came to Hogwarts
a portkey brought us there up what I
know there's one more thing
it's a bit odd if I'm honest
Professor fig says I have a rare
connection to a powerful form of ancient
magic I
I'm still learning
I know it's a lot today it is
for now it's safe to say that
letter is the
Kane who wrote I'm gonna go and play my
Eldon ring gameplay it was an honor
being here thanks for joining do you
think the deathly Hall is made from the
remains of thestrals I don't think so no
but it's an interesting fool but I I
don't know I'd have to look into it more
I'll help you find the letter Natty I'm
I'm I'll check the main gate see if you
can find another good Quest okay good
glad to hear you do not see any guts but
but still try
they will not keep us out these
battlements are very
deathly hallowsy
revelio
darkrai's path yeah
ah
lumos
oh got a big scarf
turned me into your hook rocks
very nice look at that very menacing
pet the cat speedrun
ah
it is frustrating that we do not study
Apparition until our sixth year we could
get past this gate instantly
do I climb up here oh this one
yeah
uh okay nice
doesn't look like something you could
climb up
split it
you guys ready for this
you ready for this guys
damn
what do you think
favorite movie either Philosopher's
Stone or order the Phoenix
philosopher's stone for Nostalgia
reasons
huh
is this it no
is this wrong
do I have to flip it the other way
oh like that
right okay thank you
very nice I need to find a way into the
Gatehouse to open the gate for Natty
also
what do I do here do I have to pull it
out from the other side
dead end
let's be another way in
I'm in southern
what do I do
because when you're crawling you can't
cast spells right
oh at the window yeah yeah that's right
okay cool
cool cool
smart
that looks as if it might raise the gate
I can't believe I have to write this
down but you Moon Minds don't listen
push the gate open Don't blast it if I
find it Blended pieces again I swear
it'll be the end of your lot oh so you
can blast it
is that what I'm being told
is that it
revelio
how do you lock the gate
de Paul so then Ikea okay
is that it
is
ah there we go well done
right right right okay that wasn't that
straightforward I knew you could thank
you this way I will get the door
save for me some time
sometimes you guys tell me to do
something and I just have no clue
my guess is
like
we'll need to be careful once we get
hear them
uh oh creepy
straight in the face
yeah
oh look at this
High wing
do you know that hippogriff
how do we know this hypocrite
is that the one from much earlier agreed
this is our chance go
that's a good question Liam
blasted
somewhere let me guess we can Guardian
levio set with a bunch of boxes
no is that on it
how do I do this
no Rebellion
now
all that nonsense
I hope that he stays out of trouble I
don't find it obvious which things you
can climb
is it just me
the safest place to sneak into
places
where is that crate
that was a mistake
too easy
yeah you can climb things sometimes and
then much larger things you can't climb
them
alohomora
there we go
rebelio
is there any point to coming in here or
no
it doesn't look like it
is there anything in here I need
Rebellion
I heard Nazis having an easier time of
it
Dokken is best game hello big fan of
your videos it's my first time watching
your stream live welcome thanks for
watching
ah
I know this is not a good field of view
you're going home in a wooden box
nothing
alohomora
how can you do that that's cool
should I go back and go up that not or
is there any reason for that or no
no point
deep was right
we need to save you from these
barbarians
what was that niffler
yep
foreign
am I getting warmer
oh look at this
Astrid keep an eye on my statue it's
yours if I'm seriously disappear that
line teaches us out affordable zone so I
took what I could and hit it here
20 damn deers and trees know better than
fools have been here two Blaster weeks
Manfred
nothing good that's all they owned a
pair of gloves
which um spells can you get in the mods
bye wing
it's all right
there we go
there you are
was this an evil one come on
should you sue who wren
I saw the mod where you can convert your
Mount into Cedric Diggory skeleton
all right
I like this
oh
foreign
Express must be returning from an
unscheduled run
past the highway
something wrong with the controls
the castle in the background
very magical
look at that huh my mind
[Music]
true sighted you haven't uh you haven't
got the game yet
you seem to know a lot about it
if you just watched lots of videos
[Music]
very nostalgic incredible isn't it
this is where uh Dumbledore was buried
right
[Music]
oh I like that
that was fun
good for you true size you'll have the
game soon enough
and you'll be prepared
um I've seen a few spoilers here and
there nothing there was nothing
critically I had it all under control
I've been ignoring it to find the letter
summoned it straight out of Halo's hands
I will say I did not expect to see him
cast The Killing cast at us he won't
forget this be on your gut of course
what did the letter say that Rook was
looking for Yummy you remember before
weren't you not sure where he will find
one either way it also included hallo's
orders to inspect that castle for the
poetry
pot enough to connect
officer singer she'll have to do
something when she sees it now tell me
where did you meet these hippogriffs
I've only met Highway before poppy
introduced us puppy Sweeting knows a
hippogriff
of course she does
Bobby will be relieved to know that
highway is safe you can ride a grab porn
my mind my mother will be worried I must
go
I shall have much to tell you
that was a good Quest is that it
what do I do with Highway
foreign
gotcha well welcome back
so can I just please stop summon High
Wing uh whenever I want now is that how
this works
how does the how do these Mounts work
what do I do past the highway
s now my friend
oh cool
oh I like that
okay guys I think I'm uh I'm done for
today I've got to get get to some
errands but uh I might be back tonight
um
if not I'll be back again soon okay
thanks for for dropping by everyone
see you guys again soon
take care
foreign